♪ ♪
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO, THE
CRAMPS.
RIGHT NOW PREPPING FOR A HUGE
BATTLE, BUT NOT THE ONE YOU
THINK.
IT IS OVER WHO IS RIGHT ABOUT
THE PANDEMIC AS THE OUTCOME
TURNS OUT TO BE LESS DEVASTATING
THAN PREDICTED.
THE OPINION VERSE WILL FALL ONCE
AGAIN INTO A PRISM OF TWO IDEAS.
EITHER THE OUTCOME WAS LESS
CALAMITOUS THANKS TO THE HYGIENE
AND DISTANCING EFFORTS, OR THE
OUTCOMES WERE LESS DEVASTATING
BECAUSE THE THREAT WAS OVERSOLD.
IF YOU DON’T BELIEVE ME, DOCTORS
STILL ARGUE OVER HOW THEY SUBDUE
THE SARS OUTBREAK FROM 18 YEARS
AGO.
SOME CREDIT PUBLIC HEALTH
PRACTICES.
OTHERS SAY SARS WAS NOT AS
DESTRUCTIVE AS THEY THOUGHT.
THE ANSWER TO THIS IS PROBABLY A
MIX OF BOTH.
BUT THAT SHOULD NOT MATTER NOW,
BECAUSE WE ARE STILL IN THE
THICK OF IT.
IT IS BETTER TO BE WRONG IN OR
OVER ESTIMATION THEN IN YOUR
UNDERESTIMATION.
BECAUSE THAT MEANT GOOD NEWS.
AND MAY BE THE OVER CONCERN
HELPED CREATE THE BETTER NEWS
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO BE MOCKED FOR
THE OVER CONCERN.
DO YOU FOLLOW?
I BARELY DO.
STILL IF WE AREN’T GIVEN A LIGHT
AT THE END OF THIS TUNNEL, THE
PUBLIC WILL MAKE A LIGHT OF
THEIR OWN.
TRUE, WE ARE PATIENT AND
UNIFIED, BUT WE NEED TO EAT, AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO
WORK.
WE NEED A PLAN CREATED BY A NEW
BIPARTISAN TASK FORCE, DAY,
DANA’S IDEA TO GET PEOPLE BACK
TO WORK IN PHASES.
QUARANTINE THE OLD, GET THE
YOUNG AND IMMUNE BACK TO WORK.
ANTIBODY TESTS AND MASKS GO
LOWER.
AND OF COURSE SOME SOCIAL
DISTANCING REMAINS WHICH MEANS
NO, MASS GATHERINGS.
THERE GOES MY FAN CLUB.
BUT AT SOME POINT THE YOUNGER
AND THE HEALTHY NEED TO GET TO
WORK, AND THEY JUST MIGHT
WEATHER THE GOVERNMENT SAYS SO
OR NOT.
A CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE MIGHT NOT
COME IN THE SHAPE OF A SIT IN,
BUT THE FORM OF A THERMOS OF HOT
COFFEE AND A TOOL BELT.
SO, JESSE, I WANT PEOPLE TO GET
BACK TO WORK FOR SELFISH
REASONS, BECAUSE OF MY HAIR.
EVERY DAY I LOOK MORE AND MORE
LIKE HOLLY WALNUT.
I SWEAR I AM TURNING INTO HIM.
LOOK AT THAT.
IT IS HAPPENING.
RIGHT BEFORE MY EYES.
>> Jesse: IF I WAS PRESIDENT,
I WOULD OPEN THE SALONS UP
FIRST, GREG.
JUST TO GET YOU A CUT.
BEFORE I WILL ICE PEOPLE AND
BEARING THEM OUT IN THE PLACE IN
JERSEY?
I DON’T KNOW.
THE PINE BARONS.
>> Jesse: WE SHOULD NOT
STEREOTYPE THOSE TYPES OF
PEOPLE, GREG.
>> Greg: HE IS A SOPRANO!
>> Katie: AFTER JESSE TALKS
ABOUT GOING TO THE BEACH AND
TANNING.
>> Jesse: THE TOP CEOs OF
THE COUNTRY ARTIE SAY THAT THEY
WANT THE THING OPENED UP.
BUT THEY ARE AFRAID TO SAY IT
PUBLICLY, BECAUSE THE U.S. MEDIA
WILL CHOP THEIR HEADS OFF AND
THEY WILL SAY THAT YOU ARE
MR. BURNS FROM THE "SIMPSONS."
YOU ARE A SCOUNDREL WHO ONLY
CARES ABOUT DOLLARS INSTEAD OF
DEATH.
SO WE ARE GOING TO OPEN IT UP
AND KEEP THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND YOU OPEN IT UP BY FOUR
FACTORS.
AGE, REGION, AND JOB.
AND EVERYBODY UNDER 45 GETS TO
GO BACK TO WORK.
OBVIOUSLY YOU OPEN UP SMALL
RETAILERS AND THEN YOU GET THE
SALONS OPEN QUICKLY FOR GREG,
AND THEY MAY BE MOVED TO
RESTAURANTS AND SOCIAL
GATHERINGS LIKE CONCERTS WAY
LATER.
THIS IS WAY LATER.
AT THE VERY END.
MAYBE YOU DON’T OPEN THE
RESTAURANT.
LISTEN, YOU HAVE TO OPEN UP THE
RESTAURANT SOON.
MAYBE YOU DON’T DO IT RIGHT
AWAY, THEY MAY BE THAT IS PHASE
TWO.
AND WHEN YOU OPEN THEM UP, HOW
ABOUT YOU DON’T GO FULL
CAPACITY.
YOU HAVE MAY BE A TABLE IN
BETWEEN EACH TABLE.
LIKE A MOVIE THEATER.
MAYBE THREE SEATS IN BETWEEN
EACH SECTION, BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO GET THE THING UNPLUGGED.
AND THEN NEW YORK COMES IN LATER
THAN ALASKA.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
BUT I THINK EVERYTHING HAS
CHANGED THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY HAVE INJECTED CASH DIRECTLY
INTO OUR BANK ACCOUNTS.
IF THAT’S GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO TURN OFF.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT
WHO IS BASICALLY ORDERING
COMPANY’S PRODUCE THIS, PRODUCE
THIS NOW.
AND THIS IS HOW WE WANT OF IT.
THAT IS ANOTHER TEMPTING THING
FOR FUTURE PRESIDENTS TO DO.
AND I DON’T KNOW, 4 TRILLION
FROM THE FEDERAL RESERVE, NOBODY
HAS ANY IDEA WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN THERE.
SO IT IS ALL UNCHARTED TERRITORY
TERRITORY.
>> Greg: KATIE, ONE OF THE
OTHER MITIGATING FACTORS ARE THE
DRUG TREATMENTS THAT WERE NOT
FACTORED INTO THE MODELING OF
THE OUTBREAK.
>> Katie: RIGHT, BECAUSE WE
DID NOT HAVE ENOUGH PATIENTS TO
TRY THE DRUGS ON.
BUT NOW WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME DRUGS THAT THE DOCTORS ARE
PRESCRIBING THAT ARE WORKING TO
KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF INTENSIVE
CARE THAT ARE ACTUALLY
MITIGATING THE SYMPTOMS AND
ALLOWING THEM TO GO HOME
EARLIER.
SO THAT IS GOOD.
AS THE DOCTORS HAVE BEEN SAYING
IN THE BRIEFINGS, THE DATA IS
ONLY AS GOOD AS THE MODELS OF
WHAT YOU PUT IN IT.
SO AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND WE GET MORE OF THE
TREATMENTS, WE CANNOT HAVE AS
MANY ISSUES WITH THE HOSPITALS.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE ECONOMY, I
HAVE TALKED TO A LOT OF
NONPOLITICAL PEOPLE ABOUT THIS
WHO ARE REALLY ANGRY.
AND THEY BELIEVE THAT THE
SHUTDOWN IS GOING TO BE MUCH
WORSE THAN THE VIRUS ITSELF.
AND THAT IS THE FEELING THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE WHEN IT COMES
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT PEOPLE
WANTING TO GET BACK TO WORK AND
MAY BE SOME CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE,
I THINK YOU ARE CORRECT ABOUT
THAT.
ON THE ISSUE OF NOT OVERREACTING
OVERREACTING, SOME CRITICISM
OVER WHETHER WE ARE DOING TOO
MUCH AND IF THEY ARE NOT AS MANY
DEATHS AS WE THOUGHT THAT THERE
WOULD BE BASED ON THE DATA, DID
WE OVERREACT?
YOU CANNOT QUANTIFY SOMETHING
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO FIGURE
OUT WHETHER THAT WAS A GOOD
DECISION OR NOT.
PEOPLE WOULD SAY WHEN IT COMES
TO PEOPLE’S LIVES, YOU WANT TO
ERROR ON THE SIDE OF SAFETY.
THAT’S WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS DONE.
>> Greg: SINCE YOU AND I
DEBATE OVER EVERYTHING FOR THE
NEXT YEAR YOU AND I ARE GOING TO
DEBATE OVER WHETHER IT WAS THE
HEALTH PRACTICES OR WHETHER WE
OVERSTATED THE THREAT.
SHOULD WE START NOW?
>> Juan: YEAH, WE CAN GO FOR
IT.
BUT I JUST THINK THAT THE IDEA
IS THAT IF YOU OVERSTATE IT, AT
LEAST IT GETS PEOPLE’S
ATTENTION.
OH, MY GOD, THIS IS SERIOUS.
AND HOPEFULLY THE HEALTH
PRACTICES KICK IN.
I DO FEEL FOR JESSE, BECAUSE I
THINK LOTS OF TIMES PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT ARE SAYING, OH, WE
DON’T LIKE GOVERNMENT.
GOVERNMENT IS NOT GOOD.
RIGHT NOW GOVERNMENT IS PLAYING
AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF OUR LIVES.
AND WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS A COMMUNITY AND WE STAND
TOGETHER AS AMERICANS.
I WILL SAY THIS IN RESPONSE TO
THE MONOLOGUE, GREG.
I THINK IT WOULD BE A MISTAKE
FOR US TO GET OUT TOO EARLY.
DESPITE WHAT WE MAY HEAR FROM
MR. BURNS OR EBENEZER SCROOGE
ABOUT GET BACK TO WORK.
I THINK IF THERE IS A SECOND
WAVE AND PEOPLE SAY OH, MY GOD,
THIS IS NOT OVER, NOW WE HAVE
ANOTHER WAY OF, THERE WILL BE A
LEAP IN TERMS OF PEOPLE WHO FEEL
THAT THEY WERE MISLED.
AND THEREFORE IT THEY ARE WON’T
BE THE TRUST.
THAT WILL CRATER THE ECONOMY ONE
MORE TIME.
AND THAT SLOW DOWN WILL BE THAN
NECESSARY ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
BECAUSE DON’T FORGET, PEOPLE
UNDER 40 GET THE DISEASE.
NOT SO MUCH CHILDREN, BUT A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE IN
THE HOSPITAL RIGHT NOW ARE UNDER
THE AGE OF 40.
SO IT’S NOT AS IF THEY ARE
IMPERVIOUS JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE
YOUNG.
>> Greg: DANA, I COME INTO
WORK AND I SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE
OUTSIDE, I WONDER WHY DOES
SOCIAL DISTANCING STRICTLY HAVE
TO BE AN INSIDE THING WHEN THERE
IS ALL OF THIS -- THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT CAN SOCIALLY
DISTANCE USING COMMON SENSE AND
BE OUTSIDE ON A 55 DEGREES DAY
IN THE SPRING TIME.
IT MAKES SENSE TO ME TO LET
PEOPLE OUT.
>> Dana: AMERICANS DO HAVE
THAT COMMON SENSE.
AND THE ONLY THING I WILL SAY
ABOUT THIS IS IMAGINE BEING IN
BRITAIN RIGHT NOW WHERE BELIEVE
IT OR NOT, PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
CALLING THE POLICE ON THEIR
NEIGHBORS BECAUSE THEIR
NEIGHBORS MAYBE WENT OUT MORE
THAN ONE TIME A DAY TO EXERCISE.
HONESTLY.
EVERYBODY USE A LITTLE COMMON